やあみんなドーゲンここにいるので、これは私が今やっ
た日本の2つの財政のビデオの非常に迅速なフォローアップです
そして
私がこれを作っている理由は私が明確にしたいという理由だけで私は
誰もが2つを知っていることを確認したい 以前の
動画は逸話でした。
ローカルでもグローバルでも、お金を投資するときはいつでも、個人的
な状況に関連するすべての関連情報を常に再確認することを強くお勧めします。これの良い例
は、これからやってくるアメリカ人です。
ジェットプログラムを開始する前のビデオ
では話していなかった
ことがあります。それは
、外国の銀行口座を
アメリカ人として開設した場合
、それをIRSに報告しないと、次のようになります。
そのために厳しく罰せられたので、私は
前の2つのビデオで
できるだけ多くの質問に
答えようとし、できるだけ多くの逸話的なアドバイスを与えようとしました。
でも、
詳しく説明できなかったことがたくさん
ありました。そのため、大きな決断をする前に
、税務
専門家や投資専門家に相談する必要
があります。
個々のユニークな状況と
投資する前に常に専門家に確認してくださいそれは
あなたのためのためですそして私は
あなたたちがこれを見たくないことを知っているのでそれをそこに残し
ますが私はそれをしなければなりませ
ん もう一度、私たちの
ために、サポートに感謝します。またすぐに皆さんとお話しします。